[Music]
it's late November apple picking season
is coming to an end but turning those
apples into cider will continue and
lately business has been booming cider
sales in the US have increased nearly
500 percent since 2011 and the number of
cider e's has grown more than four times
from one hundred eighty seven to eight
hundred and twenty one cider product
relies on winters natural cold to turn
it into liquid gold and now the
country's largest cider maker wants to
take a bite out of that market Adriana
Diaz traveled to Apple country to see
how this seasonal specialty is made
nestled in the Quebec countryside is a
farm so picturesque it looks like a
living postcard horses graze in the
pasture as their owner and his best
friend roamed the grounds but despite
his tranquil surroundings Christian
Barta muff is no ordinary farmer he's a
disrupter credited for reviving Canada's
apple industry it takes a village he did
it three decades ago when he invented
ice cider in alcoholic apple drink akin
to desert wine it takes advantage of
something Canada has in abundance the
cold no I pick up all when there is
minus 10 cents use in the Apple instead
of picking apples in the fall he waits
until they freeze in the winter when the
apple sugar Peaks he was inspired by a
popular drink called ice wine which is
made from frozen grapes I look upon in
the tree I ask me why I don't try with a
palm and I put in basket for frost and
that's what started with one apple tree
has grown to hundreds at his vineyard
cloths area where tourists flock for
tastings outside Barton muff walked us
through his process
do you pick it like this no I pick like
this oh you go to the trunk and you
shake it I put a lot big-big blankets
blankets and the apples are then pressed
immediately
that allows the frozen water to remain
with the leftover pulp so only the
concentrated sugary nectar is extracted
oh this thing that's ice cider during
fermentation about half of the high
sugar content turns to alcohol allowing
the cider to keep its sweet taste
despite a 10% alcohol content oh that's
delicious but it's not like regular
cider or apple juice it's sweet and tart
and fruity but I cider was once a hard
sell says Bartram ups partner Louise du
Puy then the seventies big company
started to do cider but the cider was
very bad even for health so the
government decided to take this out of
the of the market and the people they
just kept the idea that cider was a very
bad thing to have we said okay it's
apple wine since wine was there this an
apple wine oh my god what a good idea
with his newfound success Canada
approved Bar Timnath to sell ice cider
and soon other Quebecers joined in the
ice cider movement spread south to
Vermont when Eleanor Lazaro's basement
hobby of making the drink flourished
into a company we went and visited 26
restaurants couple stores and all but
one of them bought and then they rebar
sold out and they wanted more and that
was when we sort of looked at each other
said oh maybe this is not a hobby
Lazare founded Eden specialty ciders and
a year later became the first american
ice cider maker approved by US
regulators it was critical because our
whole intention when we started in 2007
was to make ice cider primarily not hard
cider and if we didn't get an approval
for a label to say I cider then we
weren't gonna do anything commercially
with it unlike Barton move in Canada
Lazare like most american ice cider
makers picks the apples in the fall not
the winter she later freezes its juice
to make the ice cider the fastest we can
make a nice cider is about a year year
and a half but there's a lot of time
where it were just letting time and
nature do its thing to develop the
flavors in the tang
anger in a barrel Lazare is considered
America's top ice cider maker and in
2016
she collaborated with the country's
largest hard cider company angry orchard
so this is Crisp apple it's our flagship
cider and what kind of sets it apart
from some of the work that we're doing
around ice cider is generally a nice
cider you're not using the bittersweet
cider apples
Ryan Burke is head cider maker at angry
orchard which is now making its own ice
cider I think I cider gives a new
experience in cider drinking it's great
as an aperitif and I think the cider
that we made with Eleanor makes it more
of a sessionable cider - there's so many
ways that cider can be its own thing and
then within that very different from
each other by style but it's not cheap
each bottle requires up to a hundred
apples and that's just one of the
challenges to making this sweet treat
we'll see what this winner brings but
you know for us last year didn't get
cold enough to freeze thaw freeze thaw
the process that you need to make great
ice cider weather is a key ingredient
but it may also be this delicacies
downfall I think that the best of a
cider is behind I'm not sure there is
eye cider here in 15 years because of
global warming - sure is it getting
warmer here yes you notice no there is
there is ten years it's very easy to
make I said every winter no no for CBS
this morning Saturday Adriana Diaz
fresberg Quebec yeah hope we don't lose
this I mean this is another reason
collective like climate change